13 games that leads the NBA one ahead of
LeBron James James picked up his fifth
last night and now has a triple-double
against every NBA team
dodge it with six foot points Robinson
Jr big dog was the former number one
overall pick of the Milwaukee Bucks who
could score as easily as doctor to make
the Netherlands to go from best to the
worst record in the NBA and not because
all these guys left but because of
injuries obviously they lose durant and
a couple of the few players the stop
just kicks it to the rent my goodness I
mean there is just there given there
just overmatched right now they got to
find some spirit some energy James
Harden Jordy LeBron there's not yet you
can buries a three he's got 14 points
Dantas pulls the trigger again picks
again dodge it
now side out as he sees another step
back by daunted with the lawn light
who's a good ball handler the math
picked up in the offseason with Memphis
in Toronto last year daunting corners
here in the first quarter the beautiful
kick-out to Jackson no good but dont't
gets the rebound goes back up and finish
it
what did he do tonight maybe not the
home they put the suit at the final but
the fourth quarter looks up but used to
think they're watching you now doesn't
matter the second quarter here's Dantas
in transition that's the layout Lucas
got 26 dodge hits thought about it now
step back three in the first half left
and look how smooth that stroke as we
said at some point he was going to get
the three points he gets to the rim
fakes the pass by adoption